un mois après l'assassinât du préfet
claude erignac trois juges
antiterroristes se sont rendus à ajaccio
sur les lieux du meurtre
le point de l'enquêté dans ce journal
près de rouen après le geste meurtrier
de trois adolescents reportage dans ce
journal sur la délinquance au quotidien
qui touchent les jeunes de plus en plus
tôt quelle réponse le monde des adultes
peut apporter à ces gestes de finesse
démunis enquête dans un commissariat
les infections en milieu hospitalier qui
font plusieurs milliers de victimes
chaque année au coeur d'un colloque
médical
au programme le matériel d'exploration
difficile à stériliser découverte jeux
paralympiques de nagano du médaillé d'or
du ski de fond un athlète heureux qui ce
qui est en fauteuil
alexandre brunet le goût du défi et la
joie de vivre et puis divine surprise
pour les électeurs d'un compositeur du
début du siècle
ils ont découvert qu'une des musiques
que figurant dans le film de titanic
était signé de leur grand père elle leur
apportera de l'or à la monsieur bonsoir
encore ce déplacement hautement
symbolique des trois juges
antiterroristes arrivé ce matin à
ajaccio un mois après l'assassinât du
préfet claude erignac
jean louis bruguière gilbert thiel et
laurence le vert ce sont rendus sur les
lieux mêmes du meurtre le point de
l'enquète avec benoît duquesne et
guillaume fêtera cette femme sera la
seule à venir déposer quelques fleurs de
son jardin à l'endroit même où le préfet
erignac a été assassiné
un mois après l'impression que les
choses vont changer je le crois pas je
l'espérais beaucoup mais j'ai bien peur
qu'on le découvre parce que nous ne
savons pas et l'arche parce qu'il a fait
ça par derrière il n'a pas fait de vent
il l'a fait par derrière ça c'est une a
tenu
encore sonné après tessa découvrir les
assassins du préfet c'est pourtant la
mission du juge bruguière et ce n'est
bien sûr pas un hasard si le patron des
juges de l'antiterrorisme a choisi ce
premier anniversaire pour venir faire le
point de son enquête il est accompagné
des autres magistrats chargés du dossier
les juges thil et le verre à la
préfecture le nouveau préfet l'attend en
compagnie de roger marion le patron de
la 6e b cpj
monsieur molière
on peut savoir ce en faisant ce que vous
voulez faire ici depuis un mois des
dizaines de personnes ont été entendues
ou interpellés depuis le nationaliste
marcel lorenzoni incarcéré pour
détention d'explosifs
jusqu'à une perquisition spectaculaire
dans les locaux du journal nationaliste
ou ribombu à bastia mais ce travail de
la police ne rassure pas les femmes du
manifeste pour la vie il y à un mois
elle était à la tête de 40000 personnes
dans les rues pour dire non à la
violence
aujourd'hui elles attendent des
résultats tangibles
ça nous inquiète aujourd'hui parce que
nous ne voudrions pas que les pouvoirs
publics donnent l'impression de jeter de
la poudre aux yeux ou de chercher des
boucs émissaires
ce n'est pas ça la justice sereine de la
sérénité le juge en réclamant se rendant
sur les lieux mêmes du drame
et pas seulement parce que la police
paraît divisée entre les hommes du
commissaire dragacci de la pj de corse
et ceux du commissaire marion de paris
pour l'instant la police comme on dit
ferme des portes et poursuit sur la
piste nationaliste celle d' extrémistes
en marge de tout mouvement connu et qui
aurait décidé de radicaliser leur
actions en frappant symboliquement à la
tête de l'état en corse le travail des
juges et de la police laisse pour
l'instant sceptique la plupart des
corses qui ne vois pas pourquoi ce
meurtre sort est élucidé quand tant
d'autres sont restés impunis
il se demande surtout quelles vont être
les premières mesures du nouveau préfet
bernard bonnet et si le retour de l'état
de droit en corse ne va pas se traduire
pour eux par davantage de tracasseries
et de sévérité de la part de
l'administration
et puis le professeur de l'université de
perpignan soupçonné d'avoir envoyé un
faux avis de décès de bernard bonnet au
journal l'indépendant
cet homme vient d'être écroué au
lendemain du coup de filet contre les
milieux proches du gia l'opération
confirme l'imbrication des réseaux
islamistes en europe parmi les hommes de
ce réseau
l'un d'entre eux et farid e mail aucun
français d'origine algérienne condamné
par défaut à sept ans de réclusion un
chef de bande
une tête de pont de la mouvance
islamiste radicale un lieutenant du
fameux ali touchent est considéré comme
l'un des organisateurs de l'attentât
contre la station port royal
arnaud boutet alain poirier
cet immeuble la police belge je le
surveillais depuis plusieurs semaines en
perquisitionnant hier vers 7 heures
elle ya découvert cette détonateur et du
matériel d'imprimerie
mais ses occupants avaient pris la fuite
sans doute informé des premières
arrestations effectuées quelques heures
plus tôt au numéro 28 de la rue wéry
dans un autre quartier de la vie ici
vivaient laroussi et soucis un tunisien
de 30 ans c'est lui qui mettait son
appartement à la disposition des autres
membres présumés du gia et souci un
garçon très discret selon le voisinage
musulmans très gentil très poli sans
histoire on voyait pas toute une année
parfois je devais recommander mois il
disparaissait il ya jamais gêner
personne
les sept personnes arrêtées partager le
petit appartement depuis quinze jours
parmi elles varient de mélo français
interpellés après 11 heures de siège
mellouk alors considéré comme le cerveau
de la bande il était manifestement la
personne a duré de référence
l'entraînement est telle qu'ils
disposaient de larmes c'est elle qui s'y
opposeraient
à l'action dé nous
évidemment résister
le plus longtemps ses proches le
surnomme le chinois farine mellouk est
originaire de vénissieux dans la région
lyonnaise
son parcours celui d'un petit voyou
converties à l'islam
le même qu'un certain khaled kelkal
kelkal qu'il connaissait tout comme
tarek l'organisateur du réseau des
poseurs de bombe en france durant l'été
95 dans cette affaire mellouk a déjà été
jugé par défaut est condamné à sept ans
d'emprisonnement
ce sont quand même les gens qui dans la
région j'ai eu une certaine importance
et aussi qui commet le l'expliqué trouve
quand même qu'il y a des
des relations et des collaborations
internationales à partir de la belgique
farid mélo qui avaient eu des liens avec
un groupe de fondamentalistes tunisien
basé en italie
il semblerait qu'il ait tenté de
reconstituer à partir d'ici des réseaux
du gia en france
nouveau développement dans l' affaire
elf dumas selon le journal le monde
madame deviers joncour proche de roland
dumas aurait reçu du groupe pétrolier
elf une commission de plusieurs dizaines
de millions de francs pour tenter de
faire pression sur l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères roland dumas qui se
défend de toute implication et qui a
fait savoir que tous les mouvements de
fonds sur ses propres comptes bancaires
étaient justifiées et déclarer au fisc
olivier caroff meriam métaoui une paire
de chaussures de luxe achetées en 92 ch
et un bottier parisien c'est le seul
vient financier établi à ce jour entre
roland dumas et christine
deviers-joncour un détail à l'époque
mais aujourd'hui rien n'est anodin car
la justice tente de déterminer le rôle
de cette proche de l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères dans un dossier de
vente d'armes à taïwan un contrat de 150
milliards de francs pour ces frégates
fabriqués par thomson un contrat qui
pendant longtemps s'est heurtée à
l'hostilité de roland dumas
un homme aurait alors proposé à
christine deviers-joncour de jouer les
agents d'influencé auprès du ministre
alfred sirven l'ancien numéro de delphes
lui promet 45 millions de francs si le
contrat est signé une filiale suisse du
groupe pétrolier se charge déjà des
dépenses ordinaires en trois ans deux
millions de francs de salaires
un million et demi pour une carte
bancaire
près d'un demi million de loyer et même
un piano de concert
l'argent reste en suisse habilement
répartis sur six comptes différents
pourtant christine deviers-joncour
affirme qu'elle a échoué dans sa mission
auprès de roland dumas
une version que les deux juges
d'instruction chargés du dossier cherche
à vérifier
après une perquisition chez roland dumas
elle se penche sur les comptes en banque
de l'ancien ministre des comptes
dont les nombreux et importants
mouvements d'argent en liquide avait
alerté la direction du crédit lyonnais
mais la loi à l'époque ne permettait pas
d'aller plus loin
interrogé par le journal le monde roland
dumas assure aujourd'hui pouvoir
justifier toutes les sommes déposées sur
son compte en banque selon lui elles
n'ont aucun rapport avec l'argent de
christine deviers joncour il semble
établi que cette personne qui est
aujourd'hui détenu à mise en examen
aperçu ça tombe davantage une gt
national
il n'apparaît pas en revanche que
monsieur roland dumas est perçu quelques
avantages que ce soit un ancien ministre
qui se dit prêt à prouver son innocence
une de ses proches décidé à le disculper
malgré sa mise en détention
un témoin clé en cavale les juges sont
loin d'en avoir fini avec ce dossier
revenons maintenant sur le geste de ces
trois adolescents près de rouen a juste
meurtrier à 14 15 ans qui suscite autant
la compréhension que l'émotion avec
cette question aujourd'hui comment un
adolescent at il pu avoir à portée de
main un 357 magnum vincent nguyen
bernard ronfler julien alexandre et
grégory ont été présentés au parquet cet
après midi ils ont à peine 15 ans mais
devant la justice ils devront répondre
d'un meurtre celui de madame auzou
l'épicière du quartier de la vierge tué
d'une balle de 357 magnum
parce qu'elle ne voulait pas leur
remettre le contenu de sa caisse
à pavilly on se demande encore pourquoi
les adolescents ont commis un tel acte
la drogue première thèse évoquée par les
habitants du quartier semble aujourd'hui
écartée par les enquêteurs
ce n'est pas justement sur le mobile de
la drogue comme on a prétendu au départ
quel mobile est elle vraiment futile ce
serait pour l'achat d'un objet dérisoire
quelque chose qui est du niveau de l'âge
des agresseurs
les adolescents n'habitent pas un
quartier défavorisé et jusque là n'avait
pas eu affaire à la gendarmerie
alexandre et grégory était en 4e dans ce
collège julien plus turbulent avait été
réorientée vers un autre établissement
lundi la rentrée ici ne sera simple pour
personne je peux pas laisser monter les
élèves classés sans avoir bien mon les
pierres près je pense qu'il ya qu'il y à
des actes préventifs affaires et
pédagogique pédagogique on le fait
toujours et préventif peut-être si ces
voitures commandées fouille des
cartables de choses qu elle doit être en
place
julien avait dérobé le revolver à son
beau père d'après la loi
les tireurs sportifs doivent tenir leurs
armes déchargées et démonter lorsqu'il a
transports mais lorsqu'ils sont chez eux
rien ne les y oblige les armuriers le
leur conseille vivement
et préconise même des sécurités
supplémentaires et vous avez un numéro
il ya beaucoup plus l'enlever retrouver
le numéro pour l'enlever ça c'est un
deuxième moyen c'est un moyen qui va
sûrement devenir obligatoire et là il ya
vraiment plus de danger la législation
sur les armes devrait être renforcée des
lois sont en projet un drame comme celui
de pavie ans souligne l'urgence
aujourd'hui si d'une manière globale la
délinquance diminue il n'en reste pas
mois que les adolescents qui passent à
l'acte sont de plus en plus jeunes et de
plus en plus violents quelle réponse
apporter à ces comportements qui
désemparé interpellent le monde des
adultes c'est l'objet de l'enquêté de ce
soir avec la façon dont la police à bord
de cette nouvelle délinquance au
quotidien
reportage un jour ordinaire ou
commissariat de villeneuve saint george
and gas burget christian tu au matin
l'officier de police a demandé qu'on
sorte le gamin de la cage
garde à vue depuis quelques heures il
est attendu pour interrogatoire le
premier de sa vie à 16 ans le lieutenant
de jean lui n'en est plus à une affaire
prêt qui implique des mineurs celui là
était jusqu'ici inconnu des services de
police
il va falloir trouver le peuple on
essaie quand même de tenir comme il faut
on n'est pas en classe pour une première
arrestation le garçon semble déjà rompu
à l'exercice toute la difficulté de
l'audition et la très vite imposer
l'autorité alors le fessier de gens va
revenir sur la course poursuite de la
veille le scooter volé et le copain en
fuite
avalanche de questions sur tous les tons
la méthode n'aura pas raison de la
détermination du jeune
il est à lui qu on me dira maintenant
façon tempête il n'a pas de scooter il
s'absente un petit moment et revient
avec un scooter tu lui pose pas de
questions
non ça ne vient pas à l'idée
d'accord le policier le sait le temps
joue contre lui
il dispose de 24 heures de garde à vue
sans aveux ni preuves face à un mineur
la sphère peut s'arrêter là tu vas bien
dire de plus
papy si tu veux prendre pour toi tout
seul moi j'y vois aucun inconvénient
mais tu me fait pas perdre mon temps ok
un silence pour seule réponse la
stratégie du repli sur soi pour braver
toutes les théories
ce qui est important c'est qu'il faut
marquer l'interdît en fait pour ce jeune
à savoir qu' ils ont créé une bêtise
cette bêtise à doit être sanctionnée en
personnellement à la bêtise a pas c'est
vrai que c'est pas des faits ça reste un
recel de vol on sait pas c'est pas c'est
pas grave en soi c'est la première fois
qu'il se fait attraper bon mais il faut
marquer très vite de nouveaux éléments
dl une deuxième affaire et deux jeunes
complices y avait l'idée qu'elle se fait
comme conneries au port bon temps
s'explique on a été gentil s'est très
bien passé jusqu'à présent hier tu à
piquer des clés avec tes copains au
collège ne dit pas non on vient d'avoir
le proviseur du collège
vous allez piquer des clés des gymnases
et du collège c'est vrai ou c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai c'est qu'il menteur
c'est le proviseur ou c'est toi tu sais
pas démarche classique de vérification
près du collège les heures qui passent
met peu à peu à jour l'emploi du temps
du jeune et de ses deux copains à charge
pour le fichier de jean d'établir la
responsabilité réelle de chacun d'entre
eux
15 et 16 ans mais la loi est la même
pour tous majeurs ou mineurs
une arrestation brest une arrestation
ainsi le défi au système va t'il
s'inscrire dans leur histoire face à la
police leurs mensonges et leurs peurs de
gosse se ressemblent toujours le
commissariat et cette première frontière
entre deux mondes
c'est vrai que le mineur carrie pour les
actes de violence de vol avec violence
les choses comme ça dans un commissariat
c'est parce que tout le reste avant a
échoué c'est l'école c'est les parents
et moi j'irai sur tous et d'abord les
parents
c'est sûr tu me dis toute la vérité tu
as déjà eu des problèmes avec la police
si jamais la première fois plus rien tt
grand père m'envoyait yoplait mais non
mais non j'explique ce qu'attend prg
spirig j'expliquerai pas raconter la
vérité d'accord aux parents il sera
demandé de venir récupérer leurs enfants
fin de garde à vue et signalement au
juge ces trois-là reviendront peut-être
au commissariat à moins qu'il n'ait
compris la leçon
c'est tout le pari et les limites de
l'exercice avant que la machine
judiciaire ne se mette en route
cet après midi l'ancien garde du corps
de de dial fayed et unique survivant de
l'accident d'août dernier a été entendu
pour la troisième fois et plus tôt que
prévu par le juge d'instruction hervé
stéphan au palais de justice de paris
après ses déclarations dans la presse
britannique traver is jose a confirmé
ses souvenirs très partielle de
l'accident mais en réalité rien sur le
choc lui même et puis le 12 mars
prochain c'est mohamed al fayed nous
perdre deux dit qu'ils devraient être
entendus par le juge d'instruction à
paris je vous propose maintenant de
revenir sur la confirmation par la nasa
d'une découverte qui frappe
l'imagination et qui entrouvre la porte
de nouvelles conquêtes
il y a bien sûr la lune des quantités
d'eau renfermé dans des glaces polaires
qui pourrait atteindre 300 millions de
tonnes et ce 50 ans après tintin le
héros d'hergé qui avait glissé sur une
plaque de verglas lunaire les
explications de patrice pollet pendant
quatre ans entre 69 et 72
les équipages d'apollo avait ramassé des
pierres et chercher des indices
en vain 26 ans plus tard cette sonde
lunar prospector a trouvé en orbite
depuis janvier autour de la lune ces
radars ont détecté pour la première fois
de l'eau nous pensons que ces réserves
oscille entre 10 et 100 millions de
tonnes d'eau à une quantité appréciable
la nasa est fort mais les deux pôles de
la lune renfermerait de l'eau gelée de
quoi remplir un lac de 10 kilomètres de
côtes et sur onze mètres de profondeur
la présence de l'eau dans l'univers et
je dirais universelle c'est ce que nous
montre notre satellite européen le grand
satellite infrarouge iso qui trouve de
l'eau partout que ce soit autour des
étoiles le jeune autour des étoiles
l'ancienne dans le milieu
interplanétaire interstellaire il pleut
même on a trouvé même de la pluie sur
jupiter est sursaturé nous grâce à ce
satellite donc l'ol est vraiment là donc
ya pas de raison qu'on n'en trouve pas
sur la lune habiter sur la lune l'on
trouvait seraient suffisants pour faire
vivre mille personnes pendant un siècle
de quoi implanter une belle colonie et
une base spatiale pour aller toujours
plus loin à la conquête de planes est
aujourd'hui organisée par l'assistance
publique conférence sur l'hygiène
hospitalière un sujet d'importance
puisque on sait que chaque année
plusieurs milliers de personnes en
entrant à l'hôpital contractent une
affection qui leur sera fatal au menu de
ces discussions aujourd'hui la
stérilisation de tous ses appareils
d'exploration comme l'endoscope on ne
peut pas stérilisés à haute température
jean daniel flaysakier et luc dachau fun
c'est une endoscopie digestive à
l'hôpital de saint denis en amphi 4000
parents quelques minutes pour explorer
le tube digestif mais ensuite commence
un long temps de désinfection de
l'appareil
car le risque théorique c'est de
transmettre d'un patient à l'autre un
microbe en particulier le virus de
l'hépatite c mais les endoscopes ne
peuvent pas être stérile 0 de
température on le fait donc à froid
quarante longues minutes avec 20
patients par jour pas question
d'attendre 40 minutes entre deux examens
il a donc fallu tripler le nombre
d'endoscopes chaque appareil vaut cent
mille francs la sécurité ça coûte cher
l'endoscopie dans un cabinet à long
terme à plus ou moins court terme plutôt
est caduc et seuls les grands sens
qu'ils ont les moyens d'acheter le
matériel adéquat avec le matériel de
désinfection adéquat le temps adéquat
pour réaliser les examens dans les
meilleures conditions pourront survivre
le prix à payer pour la sécurité
sanitaire ça c'est le prix à payer
depuis la mise en place des nouvelles
normes de direction il ya cinq ans il
n'y a eu aucune infection à la suite
d'une endoscopie à l'hôpital de samedi
au salon de l'agriculture et à quelques
jours des élections régionales les
hommes politiques de droite comme de
gauche se sont rendus dans les travées
de cette manifestation avec une visite
toute particulière pour le bétail
originaires de leur région
après lionel jospin et robert hue
notamment la question ce soir est de
savoir vers quelle est ta ble ssé
tournée edouard balladur candidat en
ile-de-france ce françoise david
elle les attend elle les pressant elle
sait qu'ils ne viennent que pour elle
mais chacun choisit sa vache et les
éleveurs qui vont avec
il ne représente plus qu environ 2% de
la population active
mais mieux vaut toujours les avoir avec
soi que contre soi
jacques chirac a fait son choix lui
c'est la limousine elles sont de plus en
plus faire mes valises et une de plus en
plus magnifique c'est un succès
formidable et je voudrais féliciter tous
les éleveurs elle édite rustique sa robe
beige elle et gasconne donc du sud ouest
l ine dans la région de cintegabelle
elle a droit aux honneurs du premier
ministre
celui qui comme edouard balladur n'a pas
d'attachés campagnarde se rabat sur les
bêtes à cornes de cellules et de
villégiature préféré la normandie et les
alpes
la maxime talent durant 7
vraiment de quart d entre elles soit la
seule une race originaire
de la suisse
une vaste potentiel mix on apprend la
déranger plus longtemps parce que robert
est lui aussi éludé ville opte pour des
valeurs sûres
la limousine enrubanné et la blonde
d'aquitaine
on va dire ça vous la préparez la mise
en pied le petit tour des gaudette
politique est maintenant terminée
l'homme de la rue que jusqu'à dimanche
allez voir la vache qui a vu l'homme à
toulouse hier soir une manifestation
anti front national qui a rassemblé
entre 15 et 30 mille personnes cette
manifestation a dégénéré violents
incidents avec les forces de l'ordre les
quatorze personnes interpellées ont été
déférées au parquet le point avec muriel
la saga et olivier combe eelv étaient
venus par milliers dans le calme pour
dire non au front national
non à la venue de son leader dans la
ville de toulouse massivement je crois
que la majorité de la population refuse
les ils y feront nationale et je crois
que ça ici ça va peser sur y compris
tous ceux qui s'apprêtent à mettre qui
l'ont fait déjà ou qui s'apprêtent à
mettre aujourd'hui comme le thème
d'halloween croqueront national à titre
inutile protestataires arrivés près du
lieu où se tenait le meeting de jean
marie le pen
les manifestants se heurtent aux forces
de l'ordre
quelques 300 jeunes ne désarmeront pas
jets de pierres tirs de gaz lacrymogène
la tension monte très vite
les interpellations se succèdent les
affrontements sont parfois très violents
plusieurs blessés policiers et
manifestants devront être hospitalisé
les 14 personnes interpellées hier soir
ont été déférés cet après midi devant le
parquet de toulouse parmi eux deux
mineurs
aujourd'hui le collectif unitaire
présent à la manifestation a déclaré que
les accords de sécurité passés avec la
préfecture n'avait pas été respectée de
son côté le syndicat de police alliance
mettons cause sa hiérarchie dont les
différentes phases d'intervention
survenu jeudi soir au moment où philippe
séguin tient son grand meeting à
bordeaux meeting au cours duquel alain
juppé devrait également prendre la
parole
revenant sur la campagne du président du
rpr qui continue sa tournée des
départements j'avais imbert jean-mi
normandin
lorsqu'on a décidé comme philippe séguin
de se rendre dans chacun des 95
départements français pour y faire
campagne il ya quelques règles observe
trois ou quatre villes par jour et comme
le transport prend du temps pas plus
d'une heure et demie passées sur place
ainsi tout le monde a droit à celles
dites tout le monde est content
merci monsieur ministre pour la droite
qui détient 20 des 22 régions françaises
la cuvée 81,18 s'annonce difficile
des positions il y en a à défendre
partout en zones rurales comme dans les
grandes villes
le rpr a donc choisi la campagne
d'explication sans négliger les formules
lorsqu'elles font mouche
il faut savoir les places et quelles que
soient les distribuer on ne peut pas ne
pas se poser une question pourquoi dans
ces conditions s'arrêter à 35
c'est vraiment trop bête je me suis
aperçu que ce n'était pas le seul à me
poser la question madame bois nestlé
était posée elle aussi aider à apporter
sa réponse est les patrons de deux
heures mais on peut continuer aller
jusqu'à bâle 5 heures mais évoquaient
simplement ces hypothèses démontre
l'absurdité de la démarche qui a été
engagé philippe séguin en tout cas est
le seul leader de l'opposition à s'être
engagé avec autant d'ardeur dans les
régions il vient aussi défendre quelques
principes
ici par exemple en languedoc-roussillon
où l'udf jacques blanc président du
conseil sortant n'exclut pas de sauver
son fauteuil grâce à des voix du front
national ou rpr tout arrangement de la
sorte et exclut les gens qui
appartiennent au rpr nous ferons ce qui
a été décidé par le rpr parce que nous
sommes là et s'ils ne le font pas ils
sont plus les repères
et je m'habitue de faire ce que je dis
je collabore déjà mais montreux philippe
séguin vient de boucler sa soixante
cinquième étape
la longue marche comme il l'appelle
compte encore 30 stations d'ici au
scrutin
si la droite limite les dégâts le 15
mars elle devra beaucoup au marathon de
philippe séguin on n'ira que les
inspecteurs de luxe comme ont pénétré
aujourd'hui dans différents sites tous
ces inspections se sont déroulées sans
entraver avec une entière coopération a
affirmé bagdad à la tête de ces experts
de l'onu l'américain scott rider la
communauté internationale extrêmement
inquiètes des événements qui se
succèdent au kosovo de nouveaux
affrontements ont opposé aujourd'hui les
forces de l'ordre ou nationalistes
albanais du kosovo une véritable
poudrière cela règlement politique et
une réaction rapide et ferme de la
communauté internationale peuvent
déboucher sur une paix durable a déclaré
tout à l'heure le président jacques
chirac langoustier des images qui
rappellent trop celle déjà vu il ya
quelques années au début de la guerre en
croatie et en bosnie opération de police
musclée avec un nom blindés hélicoptères
les troupes serbes ont concentré leurs
attaques autour de quelques villages
proches de la ville de ce prix cas à 25
km à l'ouest de brisbane à la principale
ville du kosovo peu de témoignages
directs la région est bouclée mais déjà
les victimes se comptent en dizaines
plus de 50 selon les albanais une
vingtaine d'après les autorités serbes
qui justifie cette offensive par la
présence dans cette zone de combattants
de lui ses cales l'armée de libération
du kosovo
les albanais eux contesté évidemment ses
arguments devant la presse leur leader
ibrahim rugova par le d'épuration
ethnique sur des mots eux aussi déjà
entendu en bosnie et en croatie
ces attaques font partie d'un plan
d'épuration ethnique mise en oeuvre par
les serbes au kosovo 90% d'albanais 10%
de serbes dans cette province la plus
pauvre de serbie
une haine de plus en plus forte entre
les deux communautés des centaines de
villages ou et de paysans qui quittent
leurs terres pour fuir les combats
l'enchaînement fait peur aux diplomates
européens et américains qui craignent la
déstabilisation d'une région déjà
fragilisée
les pression diplomatique s'accentue sur
belgrade qui pour l'instant fait la
sourde oreille
les manifestations se multiplient en
europe et au kosovo les pancartes tendue
hier à bout de bras par les femmes à
pristina au temps où es tu étais un
pathétique appels au secours en irlande
du nord à milliers de personnes sont
venues assister à l'enterrement de ses
deux amis d'enfance l'inca tonique notre
protestants devenu depuis leur
assassinat mardi lé symbole de la
réconciliation
nous sommes à la croisée des chemins a
dit l'archevêque catholique allons nous
prendre la route des bombes ou celles
vers la paix une paix basée comme
l'amitié de damien iehl sur le respect
et l'égalité
aux etats unis le docteur shepard dans
l'histoire a inspiré le célèbre film le
fugitif est bien le docteur shepard
pourrait être innocenté grâce à des
tests génétiques réalisées après son
exhumation en 1954 ce médecin avait été
accusée du meurtre de son épouse il
avait toujours clamé son innocence
maryse burgot dans les années 50 aux
états unis ce visage défraya la
chronique judiciaire
quelques années plus tard ces quelques
notes de génériques de vin tout aussi
célèbre l'homme comme la série télévisée
comme le film qui suivit avec l'acteur
harrison ford porte le même nom le
fugitif
le fugitif où l'histoire vraie de sam
shepard condamné aux états unis pour un
meurtre qu'il a toujours nié celui de sa
femme c'était en 1954
aujourd'hui plus de quarante ans plus
tard les résultats de tests génétiques
inédits sont révélés à la presse il
disculperaient sam shepard en 98 nous
avons les preuves que le docteur chez
pape n'a pas tué sa femme c'est le fils
de sam shepard âgé aujourd'hui de 50 ans
qui se bat pour laver l'honneur perdu de
son père l'année dernière il a même
accepté que son corps soit exhumé pour
rendre possible des tests génétiques
ces tests montrent donc que les taches
de sang retrouvées sur les lieux du
crime ne sont pas celles de sam shepard
mais celle de richard hébert ligne
présents sur les lieux du crime
ce deuxième homme est aujourd'hui déjà
en prison pour un autre meurtre
ces nouvelles révélations sur l'histoire
d'un homme qui a passionné l'amérique
vont elles suffire à faire réouvrir le
dossier
rien n'est moins sûr le procureur de
l'ohio déclare aujourd'hui que ces
nouveaux éléments sont insuffisants
le fils de celui qu'on appela le fugitif
pourrait donc bien continuer longtemps à
courir après l'honneur perdu de son père
mais épreuves paralympiques de nagano en
débuter aujourd'hui déjà deux médailles
d'or en ski de fond avec l'une attribue
un athlète qui participe pour la
première fois à cette compétition
portrait de ce sportif heureux
christophe duchiron frédérick basile
on aurait dit des couleurs de l'amérique
mais ce sont les lumières du japon
alexandra nagano c'est comme tintin au
tibet ou marco polo en chine
en arrivant ici il a été un peu dépaysé
quoique j'espère un endroit que j'ai vu
à la télé déjà où il y avait les
athlètes qui monte sur le podium
j'ai passé devant tout à l'heure je me
suis dit que j'irai peut-être y aller
moi aussi et c'est sympa de savoir que
notion on peut être s'il met comme comme
les valides quoi dans la même ville où
ils sont passés quoi olympiques ou
paralympiques
si les athlètes ne sont pas tous égaux
devant les jeux c'est évidemment parce
qu'ils n'ont pas tous la même histoire
villard de lans dans les alpes ce
février 98 comme tous les jours avec
alex la montagne accouche d'un sourire
car si alex a une petite amie
il a aussi une maîtresse et 7 maîtresses
qui l'aiment à la folie c'est la neige
tous les jours alex se sent très à la
force de ses bras musclés à 23 ans il
est déjà un champion de l'effort
un furieux compétiteurs à ce qu'ils leur
fauteuil en liberté ce qu'ils font à des
reit voici bien tracé tu prends ton
fauteuil je fus de faire toute une
journée sans trouver d'embûches quoi tu
peux prendre ton partage avec toi ta
bouffe tu vas dans un petit champ tu
manges et là tu te fais plaisir
marcher courir sauter alex a perdu tout
ça le jour où il a perdu l'usagé de ses
jambes
un accident de ski il ya trois ans une
mauvaise chute le maudit paraplégique il
ya pourtant quelque chose qui alex n'a
jamais perdu
ou alors pas longtemps c'est le plaisir
de vivre qu'ils partagent aujourd'hui
avec jean photographe et concubines
c'est vous dire qu'elle s'est passé le
portrait de son homme au révélateur
il sait pas ce qui lui est arrivé pour
lui ben c'est il a toujours été en
fauteuil plus ou moins ce que je vous ai
déjà demandé est ce que si tu avais des
gens le bain tu jeu parce qu'il y avait
des progrès dans la médecine qui re
marche une dune aux loups
je suis bien comme je suis jamais
négatif jamais fataliste je suis bien
comme je suis en photo dans la ville de
villard de lans à nagano
aujourd'hui vendredi 6 mars 1998 comme
tous les compétiteurs en compétition
alex a rendez vous avec lui même pour
l'encourager des petits japonais pas
chauvin pour un sou c'est l'épreuve du
biathlon 7 kilomètre et demi du ski de
fond et du tir de précision
pour alexandre 0 croûte c'est la
première fois que ça lui arrive
l'état de grâce en quelque sort après
une demi heure de course les petits
japonais voit venir le chevalier blanc
alexandre vainqueur pour la première
course de ses premiers jeux alexandre
l'homme qui n'a jamais aimé perdre son
temps évidemment que j'ai quand même eu
mon accident il ya trois ans donc je
sais pas s'il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui vaut trois ans manger de l'epic
encore ouais je deviens dans son genre
alex est un drôle de petit gars
capable de vous faire comprendre en un
rien de temps carbo destin ça vaut mieux
qu'un long discours
son âme est aussi pure que la neige est
blanche et ça c'est encore plus
important que les médailles on sent
deuxième match stade de france le quinze
tricolore rencontrera demain après-midi
d'irlande après ses succès sur
l'angleterre et l'ecosse
les français sont sur la route du grand
chelem alexandre kara le fighting spirit
c'est une spécialité irlandaise
on pourrait traduire sa part l'esprit de
combat pour le dernier match des
irlandais à paris au parc des princes
c'était plutôt l'esprit de baston un
plat indigeste qui a laissé plus d'un
français sur la touche
dans les années 70 le fighting spirit
c'était une belle machine bien rodée
avec des victoires à la clé dans le
jardin irlandais pour les bleus citez
souvent la volée de bois vert
irlandais et je pense qu'il en est très
bien ici nous avons perdu mais il faut
savoir quand même que c'est l'année du
centenaire l'année et tous les joueurs
et la nette était très très motivé hier
et il voulait la victoire à tout prix
dans le rugby moderne tout peut arriver
très vite arrivé donc si on veut pas que
ça nous arrive et b gardons cette
humilité qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui
pas d'excès de confiance certes mais ça
fait un bail que les verts d'irlande
n'ont pas battu les bleus de france la
der des der c'était il ya quinze ans
déjà sur la pelouse des hommes au trèfle
aujourd'hui le fighting spirit ça ne se
fera du cul en tout cas plus par des
victoires
l'irlande est devenue le souffre douleur
des cinq nations une équipe d'irlande
qui cherchent à se retrouver une équipe
qui a consommé cinq entraîneurs en osant
des irlandais battus d'entrée cette
année par l'ecosse des échos s'est
écrasé il ya quinze jours par les
anglais les anglais eux mêmes des faits
par les bleus au stade de france si l'on
en croit les lois de l'arithmétique
les français devraient facilement
s'imposer si l'on en croit les lois
d'urbi 15 verres ça fait toujours de
dégâts à 94 jours maintenant de la coupe
du monde les supporteurs britanniques
sont en émoi tout faire pour être prêt y
compris apprendre la langue française
des cours du soir ont été mises au point
à l'initiative des clubs de football
l'exemple dans le nord du pays près de
birmingham etienne leenhardt
un peu plus fort un peu de patients le
stade du stade aux toilettes dans à
peine trois mois il compte bien le aussi
être de la partie pour 500 francs les
cette leçon ses inconditionnels du
football ont entamé un parcours ils
l'espèrent les mènera le 12 juillet
prochain
jusque dans l'enceinte du stade de
france pour une finale où l'angleterre
aura évidemment sa place ne pas
apprendre leur langue
c'est faire insulte à nos amis français
il ne faut pas s'attendre à ce que tout
le monde nous parle en anglais
voudraient avoir les bases pour me
débrouiller sur place pour le logement
les restaurants et cetera tout y passe
de la géographie et l'histoire
seule inquiétude trouver des places si
l'on ne traduira qu'en substance les
insultes de la presse populaire à notre
égard
botton les fesses à ces grenouilles
visqueuse qui nous refuse des tickets
d'entrée
le professeur tentant lui de faire
diversion au cas où les stades seraient
inaccessibles
ils vont être en france dans kenya le
versailles
les spas les châteaux de la loire le bon
vin bourgogne bordeaux le champagne
capitale gastronomique du monde
connaissant la passion les enlever pour
leur équipe il est tout de même probable
qu'il y aura plus de monde autour des
stalles que dans les châteaux de la
loire
et si d'aventuré on entend dans les
tribunes quelques reproches adressés aux
arbitres avec un fort accent des
midlands on sera au moins du slavia
larbi avant de refermer ce journal la
divine surprise pour les héritiers d'un
compositeur lyonnais du début du siècle
qui ont découvert que l'un des morceaux
joués dans le film le titanic succès
mondial et est signé de leur grand-père
au delà de la fierté se sentent des
milliers de francs à la clé dédiée guyot
olivier jacquelin
[ __ ] que votre femme
cette valse le sphinx jouer sur le
titanic un musicien de villefranche sur
saône gérard poppy la connaît bien son
grand père francis poppy la composent et
en 1906 élégant mondain le compositeur
était la star de l'époque l'histoire
l'avait oublié il revient sur grand
écran devant 200 millions de spectateurs
sentimentalement c'est très fort et
c'est sur cette phrase impressionnant
quand j'ai été voir ce film avec ma
femme
j'étais relations et à ce moment là
saisi par le prince temps on fait dans
l'europe entière c'est un tabac aux
tats-unis et ses premiers hommes mais
outre l'amour familial il y aussi les
royalties que cela peut occasionner si
l'oeuvre musicale de francis paupinet a
été protégé aux états unis la famille
devrait toucher d'importants droits
d'auteur un jackpot
il s'agit donc encore une fois de
quelques centimes sans doute par par
d'ilhéou par spectateur mais lorsqu'on
parle de 200 millions de spectateurs
dans le monde on peut arriver très vite
qui auraient quelques centimes mis
bout-à-bout à des sommes relativement
importante à ce jour les producteurs du
film ne se sont pas manifestés il va
falloir éplucher les textes les
conventions française et américaine qui
protège le travail artistique des
compositeurs de son vivant francis poppy
mener grand train il était joué dans
toute l'europe
titanic a pour l'instant apporté un
milliard de dollars les héritiers de
francis poppy devrait logiquement
profiter
ainsi se termine cette édition je vous
rappelle les principaux titres à
l'assassinât du préfet claude erignac
trois juges antiterroristes se sont
rendus à ajaccio sur les lieux du
meurtre près de rouen après le geste
meurtrier de trois adolescents la
délinquance ou peuple libyen touche les
jeunes de plus en plus tôt ce soir les
trois adolescents ont été déférés au
parquet dans un instant la météo sophie
davant temps agités souvent pluvieux
puis le point route valérie maurice
demain matin à 7 heures dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac reçoit marie claude
pietragalla la danseuse étoile de
l'opéra de paris
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain soir à 20 heures merci de votre
attention excellente fin de soirée sur
france 2